when the walls have grown their own
when the world has turned grey
and the headlines are
growing day after day
as you wander and wonder how long you'll
stay lost
remember the oceans and deserts we've
already
crossed
cause next year
next year
the doors will break open next year
next year we'll breathe in the sky
though tomorrow's uncertain
we're gonna get by too
it's here
so here's to next year
[Music]
here's to next year
cause the day seems so stark
and where there's nobody leading you out
of the dark
can't let the misery
hard in your heart
the worst will pass over
and one day the waters
[Music]
[Music]
though tomorrow's uncertain we're gonna
get by till it's here
so here's to next year
[Music]
next year hugging and kissing every
single person i've ever loved in my
entire life next year
everywhere in the world
next year
in jerusalem
all of us in good health
next year
next year we will be on vacation
what
to hawaii with friends with friends
and family sure why are you copying me
next year in a more fair country next
year with our families and chosen
families
[Music]
next year in a real democracy
next year in a theater with all of you
i'm gonna say next year i'm a
boyfriend's house i'm looking for a man
a nice man
next year performing for everyone in the
same room
next year with her grandparents
next year holding hands next year i want
to be surrounded by even more of my
jewish brothers and sisters
next year with hugs and kisses with
family
next year in my mom's kitchen in long
island next year by lake michigan and
chicago with my family
next year mask free drinking gin and
tonics
next year
in health
at peace
with family at home
[Music]
it's gonna be better
[Music]
remember the oceans
and deserts we've already
crossed
good night everybody stay safe stay
healthy stay inside
next year in jerusalem
god bless